je pense aujourd'hui en 2018 il est
évident de dire qu'il est important que
les minorités culturelles ne sont pas
représentés que par des rôles restrictif
au cinéma et à la télévision
tout simplement parce que ce n'est pas
ce à quoi ressemble le monde
et
si on avait plus de deux personnes comme
ça à la télé que ce soit des noirs ou
des arabes des gens honorables j'en
arrive à admirer sur un grand écran etc
ben il y aurait moins peur de l'autre je
pense que tous ceux qui sauront utiliser
nos forums
homophobe sexiste et cessera le cinéma
c'est censé être là où on peut rêver si
même en rêve ne peut pas voir un noir
qui joue un médecin qui joue un juge qui
joue un avocat que jean policiers
comment voulez vous qu'une dame où un
jeune même puisse l'imaginer en vrai
quand je fais une vidéo où j'ai où j'ai
cinq potes j'essaie de faire en sorte de
mettre un noir un arabe une femme blonde
une indienne etc
cette foire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse se représenter parce que je sais
ce que ça fait de se sentir et peur un
peu exclu
[Musique]
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai réalisé tout ces
mini métrage à l'aide de l'iphone tout
simplement parce que j'avais rien
d'autre n'avait pas de grosses caméras
et pas de grosses équipes
alors j'ai fait avec ce que j'avais
d'ailleurs aux antilles on dit en café
des bouilles à ça veut dire faire avec
les moyens du bord il faut ce thème et
vidéo exclusivement sur facebook tout
simplement parce que je trouvais que
c'est la plateforme qui m'offrait une
plus grande liberté de créer c'est aussi
une plate forme qui a placé le partage
au coeur de son système
je pense qu'avant la relation avec les
artistes un peu plus réel est donc un
peu plus inclusive
les gens décident directement de ce qui
existe et ce qui existera par soit avec
un pouce en bas ou en poussant jusqu'à
pas longtemps je n'étais pas vraiment
sûr de ce que je voulais faire
réellement je savais que l'écriture et
réalisations jeu est une passion depuis
toujours c'est d'étudier toutes les
propositions il s'agit pas d'accepter
n'importe quoi et le but étant de ne pas
seulement jouer mais aussi être à
l'écriture et à la réalisation d'un gros
projet et ce sont ces propositions là
qui m'intéressent le plus et que je suis
d'ailleurs sur le point d'accepter
chaque vidéo possède une histoire
indépendante mais derrière l'ensemble
des vidéos se cache un fil conducteur
qui est pas si évident mais qui existe
comme s'il y avait une intrigue globale
qui se cache derrière l'ensemble des
vidéos comme une série mystère il rire
j'aime bien l'idée que mes vidéos sont
en français et ils sont appréciés à
l'international je pense que c'est grave
pour la langue française et pour la
france
et évidemment comme tout le monde je
rêve d'une carrière qui résonne à
l'international mais mais qui a comme et
puissante la france le monde est en
train de changer ça se voit tout le
monde leur marque et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs grâce à l'arrivée d'internet
et donc je pense que forcément par la
force des choses la télévision et le
cinéma vont être obligés de changer pour
que tout le monde se reconnaisse pour
que tout le monde puisse rire ou
révélant ses envies d'ailleurs le cinéma
est fait pour rêver et si on ne peut pas
arriver ensemble on ne peut pas se
projeter ensemble le projet qui me tient
le plus à coeur c'est un projet qui sera
financé entièrement par un les gens qui
aiment beaucoup ce que je fais qui me
font des dons sur tipi j'ai hâte de vous
dévoiler salut